es el mayor aumento diario de casos en
alemania desde que la pandemia comenzó
hace un año con más de 30.000 nuevos
contagios del jueves los hospitales
temen una cuarta ola de kobe 19 para
nosotros la situación es muy tensa todas
las camas están llenas intentamos
atender los casos urgentes lo mejor
posible los hospitales están llegando a
sus límites absolutos tanto con kobe
como sin él para el personal médico
ahora estamos en la cuarta ola y es una
carga enorme la edad media de los
pacientes es de tan sólo 40 años y en
una semana la hospitalización ha
aumentado en un 40% los políticos
señalan como responsable a la tasa de
inoculación relativamente baja ya que el
país no ha hecho obligatoria la
vacunación para el personal sanitario el
miércoles el ministro de salud dijo que
la pandemia está lejos de terminar y
pidió controles más estrictos solo venga
obteniendo en citación del
dominicano en tentación la verdad es que
habría muchos menos pacientes con joven
19 en la uci si todos los que pudieran
hacerlo se vacunarán puede entender
perfectamente la frustración del
personal médico que dada la carga que
supone en su vida diaria pregunta por
qué no se vacuna más gente
2 - del 67 por ciento de los alemanes ha
recibido la pauta de vacunación completa
y sólo 2 millones de ancianos tienen la
dosis de refuerzo en exteriores la
mascarilla sigue siendo obligatoria y
cada vez más espacios públicos exigen el
pasaporte de vacunación pero según una
encuesta reciente el 66 por ciento de
los alemanes no vacunados dicen no
querer recibir el inoculante bajo
ninguna circunstancia